les chéris merci d'être là est ce que
vous avez vécu des expériences
paranormales vous savez qu'il ya ghost
de ce soir il ya mulder et scully qui
reviennent sur m6 vendredi prochain vous
pas gérard castaldi qu'est ce qui s'est
passé alors moi il m'est arrivé une
chose absolument incroyable c'était en
bretagne a déjà vous c'était en bretagne
j'adore la bretagne c'est l'endroit où
on est plus regarder absolument éviter
l'écueil met donc ma mère était là il y
avait une battante et il y avait ma
première femme non il y avait combien de
femmes mais ma première femme moi
s'appelait aleri valérie et donc ma mère
alain guéridon qui lui vient de sa mère
et un cd et elle me dit tiens on va
faire une petite séance de spiritisme et
on commence cette relation au sud de
spiritisme
tout se passe bien et on pose la
question
esprit es tu là et là le le guéridon se
soulève tout seul et tape un coup un
pour 8 2 pour non moi je dis c'est pas
possible ce qui l'écarté vos mains et je
fais je vais la faire courte pas comme
isabelle bout d'un moment on demande à
savoir avec qui on est on est enfant qu
en communication et en fait au large de
de la gt afin malo il ya les deux sens
là où est mort l'oncle de ma mère non et
il a énoncé son prénom
à ce moment là on a tout sur une
trouille est épouvantable le guéridon
est parti tout seul dans la pièce il a
descendu deux escaliers creux le
guerrier oui il s'est fracassé contre un
mur là on a hurlé sa vie à une bonne
assurance vie et la règle un courant
s'est coupé non ce jour là je n'ai plus
la mairie lire il est électricien votre
ou martine aubry mais ça ils faire
permet de remettre une
j'ai eu d'anormal en soirée ce cépage
c'est ouf la tête de méricourt que tous
les enfants on doit parler mais des
images aux eyzies spiritisme il ya une
lettre qu'elle a écrite couscous comme
ça dans le ciel
son avis sur nagui boxing et nie que
j'ai une vie des plus trépidantes et les
batteries et la nouba dans le sud
dans ma famille et jusque là j'ai essayé
de me retrouver un peu au klm au calme
comme disent les jeunes
ok
[Applaudissements]
tu me retrouve seul dans mon lit comme
d'habitude a soudain vers 3 heures du
matin je me sens prêt je sens qu'on me
prend cette épreuve je sens qu'ils
prendront de la soul avait celui aidé et
j'ai vu une lumière blanche s'est
montrée extrêmement biberon ce thème
hubert blanchet et le maire branche bois
écoutez écoutez vous faites ce que vous
voulez dites-nous juste vouloir acheter
acheter du tout et vous êtes sûr c'est
vraiment réel donc soulevé le nir
blanche je vibrais et c'était tellement
intense que j'ai demandé à cette lumière
blanche de me dire oh mais moi dans mon
lit tranquillement et donc je suis
revenu dans le lit et vous ne seriez
automatiquement j'étais transpirant je
n'ai jamais autant mais c'est normal
[Applaudissements]
à
la première fois c'est toujours un petit
peu de l'eau alors vous saurez
[Applaudissements]
me suis réveillé et ni arabes ni un coq
marché rénové réalité donc j'ai pris
note des prix note pour m'en souvenir
non mais je ne m'en souvenais plus j'ai
regardé mes noces ça existait vraiment
et voilà donc c'est être raciste
une histoire pas piqué des merci j'ai eu
plusieurs aventures que rio doit sans le
sel dans un château on avait loué un
château à bordeaux ce jeu c'était 1000
euros vraiment c'était pas cher les
châteaux alloué outils ou tournage où la
loi château 1000 euros l'heure c'est
vraiment moi 4 et donc on avait pris
chacun une aile du château n'est pas un
an on était alors étudiant à l'époque on
avait moins château quand même déjà vous
y aviez des idées de ses leçons gars il
a pas donné au lieu de se dire je vais
aller en camping je vais le genre chacun
dans une halle du château
c'était génial donc vraiment option
c'était c'est bon c'est terrible et donc
un soir quelqu'un rentre dans la chance
je pensais que c'était un de mes amis
peut-être y avait un problème je voulais
me parlez pas du tout je vois cette
personne aller vers la fenêtre reste
devant la fenêtre vous avez fait des
gestes comme ça et c'est cette personne
est rentré vers la fenêtre c'est julien
courbet
[Rires]
personne est venue régulièrement et
c'est qu'ériger pas vraiment eu peur je
lui parle évidemment répondait pas mal
avec 900 mhz à regarder mais je vais
vous dire le plus mal évidemment quand
j'ai raconté aux potes le lendemain
matin bien sûr ah ouais c'est ça la
madame irma n'importe quoi alors trop
tard et était bourré machin et c'est
très bien
sauf qu'un jour on reçoit la
propriétaire du château mais vraiment
six mois après et je voyais souvent le
ce monsieur est elle nous dit oui vous
savez en bernard vous êtes ou dans le
château jeudi je suis allé là bas qui
donne sur le lac amis sympa c'était le
bureau de mon fils non mais dirait mon
fils le pauvre il est mort dont on
savait pas de la vie de cette dame jouée
le château était adorable et dans ce cas
elle nous sort une photo elle sort une
photo et moi j'avais décrit non et
décrit le mec avec mes potes mais
c'était lui je vous jure c'est
impressionnant ça j'ai plein d'autres
histoires mais ce serait l'inversé bon
tu angoisse tout le monde l'a vu dans la
jeune histoire et bien il ya quatre ans
donc il ya trois ans et maintenant je me
fais remercier d'nrj12 là je sais où
j'en ai fait les frais quand il coupe ça
peut arriver y ait un changement de
direction j'ai ressenti ça s'en va et ça
se disaient pas très bien et du coup
j'en discute avec deux élus qui ni
pourquoi pas voir une voyante jamais un
seul n'a vu super cartésien honnête ça
j'y vais dans 14e et je vois une voyante
une v3 prédiction c'est maria est la
première et me dit très rapidement je
vois entourée d'animaux sains j'aime
beaucoup d'animaux sera donc là vous
avez fait où est la vie de ta mère je te
promets que c'est vrai deux mois après
le patron d'nrj
que de noms que nouveau stefano
m'appelle et me dit tu vas faire ou ce
dont l'un des animaux et tout ça elle
avait des bonnes prédictions la haine
incroyable
clairvoyant même deuxième et la n avait
pas donné l'audience
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
deuxième prédiction il me dit très
rapidement ensuite vous allez rencontrer
votre idole alors comme le télé le
téléphone a sonné que vous m'avez appelé
bmp je me suis dit mais c'était vous est
pas complètement voit cette époque là on
se connaissait pas bien y avait pas de
sens si ce n'est pas vous votre idole
mon idole et l'époque la valeur a dit
que des comme vous jure que c'est vrai
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone du
producteur était invité à bercy au
concert de justin bieber nom est tu
pourra le rencontrer je suis un des
seuls je suis un des seuls
bizarrement je suis un des seuls barbare
quand j'arrive au concert à bercy on me
dit l'a pas encore joué tu paies dans sa
logeuse aussi j'allume a pris sa carte
bleue oui mais oui mais oui mais oui ok
tu va casser tout mais alors et donc moi
je vais le voir un âge les veux juste
quelques minutes dans sa loge après la
3e prédiction c'est quoi et la troisième
a fait une prédiction pour 2018 vous
allez rester beaucoup chez vous on n'a
pas bien la troisième c'était vrai
c'était que dans les cinq ans donc c'est
à trois ans et demi cette histoire là
c'était quand on est cinq ans je ferai
du cinéma non ils y arrivent taxi 5
c'est fou c'est pas fou alors je peux
pas t'en dire plus parce que même toi tu
seras surpris mais arrive taxi 5 et
messi gastambide je peux le dire
maintenant parce qu'il est pas là et
j'aime préfère faire la maladie en
connaissons pas la guerre tandis que
debbie bloquer un petit peu c'est pas
besson qui bloquait donc vous avez joué
donc pas que 6,5 on saura ça mardi voilà
en tout cas il m'avait prédit des
cinémas c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire souvenez vous on pour le futur
assez bon merci